[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
with that we make the smooth segway and
desean salisbury morning host of the
sean salisbury show on sports talk 790
in houston sean it's
an exact science i don't care how many
people are involved
uh whatever drills whatever you know iq
like how do you
you're able to find your guy it's not
that easy so the niners have their guy
in mack jones apparently
urban meyer's got his guy and the jets
have their guy
and then you're going to have maybe
justin fields or trey lands
not all of them are going to succeed
that statistic said bobo brazil dan
i was a bobo brazil guy too that just
means we're old okay so we go back to
that
yeah um yeah dan it isn't you can
evaluate
everybody has a differing opinion some
people love shorts and a t-shirt
some people need a little bit of film
heck for trey lance and mac jones both
of them have started the same amount of
games when we ripped trey lance well
mac's done it too but he did it at
alabama it's not and the statistics say
dan that you know one of these guys or
two are going to be really
they're going to be stars um the third
guy is going to be pretty good
and the other two will be floundering
around trying to find their way whoever
those five are
and the interesting thing about this is
is
it maybe a guy a lot of times if you go
to a better football team or the one
more equip like ben roethlisberger
remember dan when he was falling
he got to go to a team that didn't have
to rebuild they just reloaded
in pittsburgh and now he's got a hall of
fame career so whatever it is you go by
and we all have a you know
the way we view quarterbacks the way we
look at it you got to be a little lucky
you got to be well coached and you got
to have something that we don't see
and it's the things we don't see a lot
of times
in a quarterback are the things that end
up being the difference maker in between
good and great and we draft top five
quarterbacks for one big reason
aside from winning championships we
expect them to be hall of famers dan
that's we do if you're drafted a top
five quarterback there cannot be a lot
of ifs by your name
but if i said mac jones was gonna have
the career of kirk cousins
would that be a successful draft pick
for the niners
sure it would you'd win a lot of games
but when we say successful in the top
five dan
we're not that's not good enough that i
mean the perception see we want
everybody to be brady mahomes
manning where you got to win champion
right away we're in that instant
gratification if you're not good after
two well
you you're not patrick mahomes what
happened you're not tom brady well
you're right those guys there's few
that's rarefied air
kirk cousins is going to leave this nfl
when he does with a lot of numbers and a
really good career vinnie testaverdi
hell of a career you know not winning
super bowl champions as a starter great
i can go through there's more of far
more of those guys
than there is guys that were drafted in
the first round we say man what a great
player look at the 83 class
three hall of famers two really good
careers and todd blackledge
didn't have his career great broadcaster
great guy didn't and can he oh brian and
tony easton had good careers
yeah but dan so yeah if mac jones has it
but when you draft him third dan
when all is said and done when you and i
are sitting around having a drink or
we're evaluating on television or radio
we're gonna say yeah but he didn't win a
championship
we don't say that about the left tackle
or the right guard we only say that
about the quarterback or the pitcher in
baseball
but with kirk cousins he was a success
story because he's what a fourth round
draft pick they had drafted rg3 the same
year you know mac jones doesn't get that
benefit
he's not you know he's moving up they
moved up and they're going to go up
there and get him
but trying to understand like justin
fields
did everything that you i guess you're
supposed to do
he played big in big games played hurt
um but i don't unders i don't understand
this i don't understand the justin
fields
where teams are i think he was dropping
i'm gonna tell you why dan is i'm trying
to figure out too let's see after the
game against clemson and then the
national title game when he was toughing
it out
outplayed trevor lawrence in the
football game what happened between we
didn't have a combine right dan this
year
so what's happened between the time that
game ended in january
to now i'll tell you what's happened one
person starts the verbage
and then the next person buys in and
then people start to panic see we
do everything we can to find out what's
wrong with the guy
as opposed to all the great things
that's right none of them are a perfect
science
none of them are perfect at what they do
but he's got far more great traits and
qualities
than than things that are negative so
what happened is that
it starts to snowball oh somebody said
he didn't work hard
what about all of us that believe he
works hard or that he does get through
his progressions
or that he does put his foot in the
ground and he is tough and that players
love being around him the elevates the
play
only thing i can see with justin fields
uh
i watch the tape and see about 80
percent of his throws this year
and he makes good decisions he's a
winner he's tough he's competitive
yet somehow on the verge somebody
started to say well four guys don't like
him i can't draft him if you love him
draft him i think it's absurd
and i think we're irresponsible
irresponsible a lot of times
in the way we judge quarterbacks if
you're a person that just watches one
game don't come at me and tell me you
know
what justin fields is doing watch him in
shorts and a t-shirt watch him in film
talk to the backup quarterback talk to a
wide receiver talk to his coach
those are the people that are around him
all the time the person sitting up in
the upper deck
or that's going on a hot take show and
saying you know what i saw him he threw
a pick in game four against indiana
and he overcame it too so i tend to look
at the good things
as long as there's it's not overbearing
that the you know a guy
doesn't move and he throws too many
picks and there's so many things against
him
justin fields is a hell of a player and
i think it's irresponsible and absurd
for us to judge a guy in shorts and a
t-shirt more than we do in pads
and to start saying things about
somebody that you quite frankly don't
know enough about
the local coverage in houston with
deshaun watson now you have sponsors who
are starting to fall by the wayside
has anything changed locally with desean
watson
dan four months ago if you just said
sean and we've talked and we have about
him about his game and
if when he demanded to trade and all
that but before that even and this
what's going on now
the court of public opinion would have
been he was held in as high regard
on and off the field as anybody was in
their city
any quarterback any player charity
giving great teammate
uh just just a great a great person a
great football player
the i'm just going by the court of
public opinion i i'm not
implying guilt either way both sides
deserve to be heard and let
the the the system take you know the
justice played out and then we'll make
an opinion
but the court of public opinion it's 180
degrees different than it was dan
for all the stuff they said that he was
then
the majority of the people that come on
my show or the talk in houston is
180 degrees different now regardless of
what happens
unfortunately or depending on how you
look at it
his his reputation the damage that's
been done by this
or by him is going to take a long time
and i don't know if he'll ever be able
to fix it but the court of public
opinion is
now is uh he's not going to play it down
this year
or what have you this is even before we
know if guilt is there
but because and people are saying well
are 22 people lying
are four people four is too much one's
too much it's it's it's
180 degrees different dan than what we
thought about uh
desean watson or what the public thought
about deshaun watson four months ago
is he tradable today no
i mean now there's always somebody who's
who if i mean as we sit today and i
asked that question yesterday
just as we sit today knowing what we do
and don't know
can you trade him or would you take him
i don't know how you can
now four months from now we may be
saying yeah you can trade him and yeah
you could take him because it's all been
cleared up but right today
you're basically saying your team one
side
and devaluing or diminishing the
importance on the other side
football's not more important it we have
to wait
so do the techs and so do other teams so
does anybody pass in judgment on both
sides
we have to wait dan because if somebody
did take him on
they'd simply you'd be giving him away
as a football player
i think just the pr move and what's good
for your franchise
you can't move him and you can't you you
cannot trade for him today
he's sean salisbury the host of the sean
salisbury show sports talk 790 in
houston
you had 12 starts in your career you won
six of those 12 starts
but if i look at the ratio of starts to
quality quarterbacks you defeated
you might be up there as one of the
greatest quarterbacks of all time
because hall of fame close close
you beat jim everett you beat bobby
brister
you br beat brett favre you beat john
elway
you beat steve young you beat jim
harbaugh
and guess what 6-0 against them it's the
only reason why i did
because i didn't play any of them a
second
that's okay it's okay
you you you you you're out of the
country you went to canada
if you want to know how great my starts
were and how quality just asked me
and i'll remind elway those guys about
it all the time brother
if you ran into favre would you say how
long would it take before you'd say
yeah i beat you brett i'd well i'd say
you know
it's still hey it hovers over him i lost
to salisbury
i i i would say hey brett it's great to
see you man boy last time we saw we were
hanging out having a blast at elways
tournament and by the way i beat both of
you guys just so you know
undefeated and where's steve young at i
whooped his rear end too
while all three of those guys are
wearing mustard colored jackets
and i'm sitting here talking to you
paulie do you have sean salsberry stats
against one of these guys
yeah you mowed his grass sean you were
30 20 for 33
292 and two touchdowns favre had three
interceptions and no touchdowns
oh and by the way just i i don't know
dan by the way
by the way what else do you have against
elway in a driving snowstorm of course
i beat him in his building i went in
there in front of his family
and was the nfl player of the week just
so you know
thank you bob and they're all laughing
at me sean hey everybody finds a little
luck
six times in their career yeah there you
go thank you sean
have a great weekend great to talk to
you i love you guys i appreciate you
having me on
sean salisbury morning host of the sean
salisbury show sports talk 790 in
houston